in Ohio state leaders ordering polls
closed just hours before primary voting
was set to begin there the governor
making that controversial announcement
after a judge initially denied his
request for the election to be postponed
over coronavirus concerns and barber is
live in Columbus Ohio with the latest
good morning Alison to say that things
have been confusing here in the last 24
hours or so is a bit of an
understatement some people actually
tried to show up to various poll
locations this morning thinking that
they could vote only to then find out
that it actually was not happening today
they were greeted by signs on the door
saying that it had been postponed
yesterday Governor Mike DeWine said in
order to protect the health of Ohio
voters they needed to postpone in-person
voting he said that he didn't have the
legal authority to make that change so
his office filed a lawsuit to ask the
courts to approve a delay on the
in-person vote and extend absentee
mail-in voting until June 2nd but a
judge in Franklin County denied that
request it seemed voting was back on
poll workers were told to show up then
governor DeWine announced that the
election would not happen and Ohio's
health director dr. Amy Atkin will order
the polls closed as a health emergency
and he said this quote Secretary of
State Frank LaRose will seek a remedy
through the courts to extend voting
options so that every voter who wants to
vote will be granted that opportunity
just spoke to that man Ohio Secretary of
State Frank LaRose he told us that he is
now preparing for legal challenges but
he says he is confident that the
decisions made in this state are legal
and he says they acted as quickly and
decisively as they could listen here I'm
confident that we made the right choice
and the legally correct choice as well I
don't think any of us that serve in
positions of responsibility can ever
look back and say we did everything 100%
perfectly right hindsight is always
20/20
what I know is the
governor Devine acted to protect health
and safety what I know is that I
immediately responded to protect the
integrity of our elections and the
confidence people have in our elections
I know that the governor stands by his
decision I stand by mine and the
Secretary of State is now urging voters
in this state to go online to vote Ohio
gov and register for those mail-in
ballots Edie all right Alison Barbara
thank you